hello again
good day good morning uh we are
exergetica
uh javier guevara and me gustavo
restrepo
uh during that presentation we will talk
about mathematica and computational
thinking the player
applications in engineering
we will show you uh
some success cases from oil and gas
industry
energy efficiency and chemical
industries of application of
compensational
thinking solutions or methods in order
to solve
engineer engineering problems and
we will talk about exergetic sargentica
the idea behind our startup company
and our value proposal
who we are we both are chemical
engineers
with more than 10 years of experience
working as process and project engineers
for latin american engineering companies
in the sectors
in the industries mainly of oil and gas
power energy efficiency and chemicals
we have a large experience in
process simulation dynamic simulation
modeling equipment sizing analysis
analysis of equipment's
operation uh hydraulics heat transfer
uh energy efficiency um
and also in implementation of a deep
artificial
neural networks and also data
engineering
exergetica is a colombian company start
a
company founded in 2017
with the idea to offer knowledge based
solution to latin america
companies and
producing companies related with
oiling s chemicals and power
our idea is to offer solutions
for process analysis and system modeling
and
we decided as we decided to use
all from mathematica and system modeler
as main instruments for our developments
and services we have got from
work from research support so we started
to work
sergei
so what is the idea behind the concept
of
exergetica um
in our experience of in engineering
companies working as project engineers
we found that in
some common inefficiencies
that are common to the companies we knew
uh and they are associated with the lack
of automatization processes that leads
to
inconsistencies mistakes rework and
we will talk about more detail about it
later and uh in order to
to to fix the inefficiencies we started
to talk
what is the best way to solve to fix it
uh
we found that we the the best way is
implementing computational thinking
thinking to improve
this uh enduring activities uh
on procedures uh we have to take into
account that
uh in spite of that we are now using
modern simulation programs
uh the same procedures and activities of
delivering
documents and resource simulations have
not changed
in the last 40 years or 20 years
and there is a lot of
activities that could be automated but
at least in the latin american reality
system being performed as it was done 40
years before
um on the other hand
uh in our studies we miss mathematica
and wolfram language
and we know the features and
characteristics that
makes possible to implement
computational thinking successfully
uh in order to improve the engineering
practices to improve the engineering
methodologies
and perform the calculations efficiently
and accurately and finally
but not less important is the fact that
we do love
simulation and modeling and that is the
fact that motivates
us to create exergetica with the idea of
implementing computational thinking in
engineering
uh after we created our company we
started
to think about how to develop uh the
beloved
what will be the areas of the market
audience
to our developments and services and so
we stated
um our four
primary hypotheses that guide us
in our developments
so let's talk about that engineering
inefficiencies that we found
in our practice as project engineers
mainly is the fact that the information
is dispersed in various sources formats
media
and also the engineers have to work who
are being working
while working now uh in different
interfaces with different programs
they have to switch with among them
between them and
deeply that leads the to a big
possibility to
inconsistencies appearing appearance of
inconsistence
mistakes and more serious more seriously
design mistakes and it works
this with the consequence of
more time to execute projects
and increases cost um
also we found that the engineers use
multiple versions
of template instruments calculations as
these
instruments usually are the
designs in calculation shifts commercial
calculation sheets
and this lead that engineers can modify
them uh
and in one only engineering engineering
company
engineers can give different results uh
for the same problem but it's an
unacceptable for an
engineering company it's a big quality
problem and
uh other problem is that
there is a limited capacity of data
analysis that makes possible to
convert raw data into useful information
uh and all this is associated with lack
of optimization
of engineering processes
so uh when we started to think how to
solve these problems we
understood that the best way is to
implement
a computational thinking methodologies
and solutions that are characterized
characters
are being the characterized form
in that they are uh offer faster results
more accurate
reliable replicable and efficient um
computational thinking solutions offer
to
the engineer practice uh enhances
possibilities from calculations that is
analysis data
diagnosis prognostics um
and also visualization interactivity and
the possibility of real-time simulations
that what is not possibly using the
standard
methodologies and instruments also
computational thinking solution gives a
broad capability to implement new
computation technologies
for the solution of problems of
increasing complexity
finally all these will be reflected in
an increasing profits and effectiveness
of the
engineering companies that will work
with us
in implementation of computational
thinking in their processes
so why we decide to use mathematica well
as we knew the features the main
features of mathematica and wolfram
language
uh that is function of programming the
format that is very interesting for our
idea of improving uh engineering
procedures
interactivity flexibility and the
supports of warsaw from research
but do you you can find it using open
codes
applications we stated the following
premise
engineers most focused in
proposing develop the current
mathematical models based on the
engineering knowledge
uh and the that engineers must
solve uh that models using the correct
instrument that is
well from language uh the the we make
the part of
the mathematical apparatus so we
considered an engineer
most to solve engineering problems and
mathematical problems must be solved
with the correct instrument for us it is
a mathematical system model
so taking of the account does those
factors uh we establish
stated this um
primary hypothesis that um
we are being improving as we are
progressing in our development processes
um
the first of that hypothesis is that
mathematical notebooks are an
useful tool to increase productivity of
engineering projects
execution that is we want to offer
an unified interface to perform
calculation
and to redacts
reports and it is based on the idea of
an intelligent reports
based on mathematical notebooks
the second hypothesis is that using
mathematical system wheelers we can
develop
not only customized application balance
applications of genera who used oriented
to
the particularities of latin america
markets and taking into account in our
our experience as engineers we know what
parameters
uh are needed to take into account in
design
and process analysis and that's what we
have been done with developing
developing
our products um third
world foreign language means the
possibility uh to successfully
introduce and implement industry 4.0
solutions in latin american market
uh that is growing um that solution that
kind of uh
industry 4.0 solutions uh
are not developed as in other countries
in north america so
we have the possibility to enter in that
market and
make interesting developments they're
here
finally the our hypothesis is that
small and medium companies and
engineering companies
have limited resources
personal and time for research and
development
activities this is an opportunity for us
to offer a
knowledge-based solution to that
companies
so in the second part of our
presentation javier will
explain you how we have
started to to improve the hypothesis and
uh how to understand the
current state of our development
okay we can start with the first
hypothesis progress
the first hypothesis says a mathematical
notebook are an useful tool to increase
productivity and of engineering project
execution
so as gustavo said we found that
some problems we have in the engineering
companies is that the
engineers have to write the text on the
documentation of the project in in
one tool and have to make the
calculations in another two
so we propose a unified environment
using mathematica
to perform both the reduction and the
calculations
that provides an interactive and
flexible interface
so we are presenting now four of their
success cases we have for this
hypothesis
the first one is the the during time
calculation for a
water pipeline so you can see here uh a
schematic
of the system with all the bulbs
in the different locations and we
develop a differential equation
a problem to estimate how this
pipeline will drain so in the next
graphic you will see the
water flow versus time
this is some of the applications you
have with mathematica
and they are more interactive and
flexible that the current
developments they have the second
example is the crude oil
temperature and we have some problems
with
heavy crude oil in latin america so we
developed a problem with the using the
bernoulli equation
this is a diagram for the process and we
estimate that when you
heat up the that heavy crude oil you uh
reduce the cost of this those um
this um pumping operations
so you can monitor using the next
example we
use the manipulate and we can see
how the cost will be depending on the
temperature that affects viscosity
flow and eventually the cost
the next example
uh here in that graphic the blue line
indicates the cost associated
with electrical energy consumption that
is a pumping
energy and the red line indicates the
cost associated with a consumption of
thermal
energy that is the heating energy
and we see how as we increase the
temperature
the the pumping costs
decrease as the
the thermal energy increases cost
decreases
but we find that there is a minimum
indicating that there is an optimal
solution
okay the next example is the simulation
of a
discharge line of an ammonia vessel we
have some
liquid ammonia bumping from the pressure
vessel to the
atmospheric storage tank
and the objective of this model is to
minimize the evaporation of the
ammonia so we develop another tool
using manipulate and you can see the
parameters of the process
and you can change the the parameters
just like the another example and you
can have
pressures and flows temperatures from
this
system and the idea was to give the
operator the plants operators and
instruments in order to check
the steam for the vapor formation from
liquid ammonia
in order to minimize the
generation through this temporary line
okay finally we can show you this
example of a full document of the
engineering so you can
specify objectives scopes
all the theory you have and the analysis
of the results
combined with the inputs and equations
in mathematica
so the advantage of this solution is you
can specify
one input in only one
line of the project and
if this value change over the time of
the project you only change in one place
and this
automatically uh um update all the
calculations
you can have drawings uh graphics to
show the complete behavior
you can put even manipulates
and interactive tools to prove
that how the system will behave
under the circumstances and we have
some drawings of the project too so you
can combine all the information around
the project in one
simple and unified application
show the results of the project also in
mathematica it's important to
to to have the possibility to manipulate
the calculations in order to show the
clients the the
the reason of the design
decision taken by the design equipment
say the design team
okay let's see the the second hypothesis
latin american companies
are expending significant amount of
money on the acquisition of specialized
software that are not fully
exploited so there are some
specific specialized software that we
use in the
development of the engineering that you
are not using it
fully and it's significant cost in the
project
so we present you idroset it will set is
our first library
in system modeler you can see here the
library with different blocks and you
can combine it
like you see in the right image and you
can build
anything in j in the process you need to
evaluate the hydraulic networks
there's an example of that hydraulic
networks so you can combine
pipes accessories vaults and even the
all the elements in the control loop so
you can provide an efficiency solution
more affordable for the companies
and you have all the experience we
collect in our experience
in process engineering and develop this
to help you to
reduce times reduce costs and provide
more
reliable results from this model
the second tool we have to present you
is concept concept is an application
based in mathematica
and you can use it to a equipment sizing
and capital and operative cost
estimation
this example this is a window from our
development
and all the visual visualization was
developed in mathematica too
in the first step you can specify all
the process data
you can type the values of the process
variables
and you have a simple menu to select
number of
the units you have and the type of the
equipment
currently we have developed this tool
for pumps
but we are including more process
equipments
the third hypothesis is the world from
language brings the um
possibility to successfully introduce
and implement
industry point for zero solutions in
latin american market
and so gustavo are explaining us how
meta models of complex systems will help
us
to do this example within the
demonstrations
that it is possible to build to get meta
models of complex more complex models of
simulations dynamic simulations uh
implementing or using training deep
neural networks
so as we get data for from another
simulator
we reduce the order of that simulation
and get a simplified method model
that is linear and correspond to the
structure of the
deep neural network design for that
purpose
the results of time were
good and we have to say that
results it is easier than make a
regression of all the factors as
we can train all the parameters that
leads you lead us to
to predict the values of all the neither
results
okay another um
another application we use in this
hypothesis
is to make process and data analysis for
the industry
so we can analyze analyze the behavior
find relationship between variables
show relevant information and build the
model kpbis
or key process indexes so in this
example we see a
large amount of gaze consumption data
this is a gas not a natural gas
and distribution system in colombia and
we use the information about
a week of consumptions of different
industries for two different systems
and we found that all the peaks of
consumption are not simultaneously
so we can specify the maximum capacity
of all systems
and doing a data analysis of those
consumptions
so some of the peaks are combined and
somewhere else don't
and this example was made for two
different systems you see the graphics
over there
finally we can see therefore hypotheses
so the small and medium companies and
engineering companies have limited
results for
research and development so exergetica
has two
main partners in colombia and one is
nova tech nova tech
consulting company we develop with them
on incident data analysis for kpis
construction
so you can see how um you can combine
the information from the incidents
with the personal information of the the
person
the in the inlet and outlet of the
of different processes and how we can
measure that
in one simple tool in mathematica
certain tech is another company it's an
oil and gas engineering company
and we developed with them and tool for
evaluate different
alternatives to improve the operation
performance in the crude oil treatment
facilities
now why exergeta exergetica provides
solutions
with using two principal concepts
computational thinking and digital
transformation
so we think that is very important for
latin american market right now
we have expertise modeling and
simulation different equipments process
dynamic systems control loops and using
neural networks and
big data as you see in this presentation
the experience in execution of
engineering projects
both have experience in oil and gas and
chemical
power plants distribution and
transmission systems
energy efficiency assessments and last
but not least
we have the support of wolfram research
to develop
a small medium projects in latin
american market
and finally we can talk about the
problems we have in the current industry
in latin america
these problems can be solved using a
computational thinking
mathematic is a tool that help us to
solve
traditional problems but with different
approach
and allow us to bring the digital
transformation to our industries
as engineers and educators and finally
we think that engineering knowledge
combined with computational thinking
give us our competitive advantage from
other companies
and exergetica in addition to
warframe research can provide effective
solutions for engineering
so thank you for your time do you have
any questions or comments
okay meanwhile we can see the last slide
so this is our contact information uh
gustavo restrepo and javier guevara
you can visit our website and
exergetical.com
and we have a blog and when we talk
about the
different um aspects we see in our latin
america
and market and our developments in the
industry
so free from feel free to contact us on
our social media or directly on our
emails okay
question possible
yeah i didn't see their questions
i see them on there would you like me to
read them to you guys
yeah yeah thank you okay uh so mads is
asked
how hard was it to train users to use
wolfram language do you need to provide
any training for them
okay for the moment we have uh
only we are used uh warfarm
language and we have offered uh the
results or the analysis to our clients
they their
directive for the moment have not used
war from daily but they made
they get their results to us
but we used mathematics and
education and the feedback i got
that time is that
students feel that it is uh
easy to to learn language
i remember a student
that said me that she
considers before that primary
programmation is not for her
but when she met he started to use
mathematica
she understood that that is uh
he has the capabilities of programming
the difference is the language she was
using before
and the flexibility of war from
language i have to say the the the
learning
curve is this is speed
users will uh
[Music]
relatively fussy fast can start to
use correctly the word from language
functions
a couple more from ads
what do you share with users well from
language codes or only visuals such as
manipulate
okay i will say it depends some some of
our
developments are planned to be online
so you can have a subscription or
this is an and working progress right
now
but and in the project we are developed
we
combine the the all the inputs and
equations in
mathematica and enter and we
developed the notebook and this is the
final product the notebook with all the
texts and
all the equations and the manipulates
are immersing that code
so the client is not pro
and it's not um
interactive with the with the code
itself but with the solution
but we have some clients that are a very
enthusiast about the the word from
languages
and we are trying to make some um
arrangements to
they have a proper license and maybe
they can have
some training for using that
capabilities of of warfarin languages
and yeah
for these last users however mentioned
that who wants to dilate the directly
used war from mathematica
we consider the possibility to
to develop templates
of calculation reports in order
that they will perform the calculations
using the
the notebooks for that kind of uh users
we have to
to to teach to use the
the tool the language but we have
experienced teaching uh
often languages universities in colombia
not only to students but also to
professors of the
universities who acquired the software
and one last one from ads can we see the
projects or some sample notebooks for
oil projects
at least some notebooks not containing
confidential information
um yeah through our website we are going
to
to to update our website in order to
show
uh these successful success cases we
showed today
um and as we
this year started to to execute a
consulting project we have more material
to show
yeah i i want to add something we we
work
in in partnership with wolfram so we
have developed some webinars as well so
we can
show you more uh detailed information
about our developments
and as gustavo says we we will uh
upload some of the examples in our web
page in the next few months
and finally just from mads and roy great
job guys great work
you